This
last
excerpt is taken from original tape W sixty four.
Cruiser.
I
haven't swirls.
Of but just loose the police record.
Maybe get a call
from the
houses and you
show them how they you know there is
a lot of casting call luck out.
So you know when they get the man but no bones
livery or something like that.
He and sometime watch this in the
past but out of the affair you leave us.
Or you
are right.
That's when the lady get
caught with her. She
go see see her get caught in a drug and
everything to tell who she was working for with a new
thing. So they gave all kinds of
military is because there's no
way to know like she's like the event that
is about two years.
Who's there. And then she calls the media and then these two things a lot of
them on the she can go away.
And then they get a bad you know and they get a back out to
say the least come back the drug
again and it is that we don't get the
time that he may come out of you know like
peer
like the. And there's this man that they
wanted. For the trade
so like the other people in Mission Impossible. They
knew that who they wanted. So they got the man
I
was the jail and.
Soleil they had the big
thing is they will cheer and then they
head back to head the real mess. No.
First when they came in they had the men in there. They had a dummy in the back of the
chair and that's how they get the man out of
prison and they went there they used the same thing thinking.
No they walked
him and then they took was all right and all of
this and their day was coming.
So many was trading. People for each other.
So he played a smart because he knew that they were going to shout after they
traded and then they all
wore blue book whose
jackets and so the men were ordered a
long trench
coat he gave the lady change grow on
her. And and then when when
they when they got
another start reading it turned their back and walked
away so that I start shooting that
the. Relay had met only
a great deal.
A
year or we
were. Late.
When this this man and this lady was
fussing about the kids coming over now the
young girl
and they say that.
By stating what the kids over the years so many
men in the lady's dog. So the couple
nights after
that the magic came
back and here broke the windows in the lady's
house and then the lady calls the call the
police and then that the two guys guys
came in and they went to go see about it.
Liz There's been a so they just went over to talk to
the man. So the man was fixers cause. So he did listen to wording. He said.
He was and he said that the man said that he was the one
that
was and then the other Leahy women near those
the really they call the cops Louie.
And then
their lives they switched around the aftermath
again. To them and that night. Everything was
cool and then the other
night. When they came back he went to the house
and he had a girl or a
kid. And they call. And then.
And then they went around the corner so that the guy went around a corner and that they
called Adam twelve guys
again. So then when he would get rid
of so then they chased him and chased
them. And then he where you get really
really run over war. This is a clue in a while because I'm
right there.
You're
right. Good movies
like
The public will tell
you who has a
nice day. He was
ages
like and there is act of him and he was well
like all these guys where we live and there's like a computer build
the lights up like that.
And the fillet was there to show he knew karate and all of
us and they used to come out and knock them out many
things. No he's not love everything and then we'll
lose as a general suck.
The label get a phone call.
They had like that so I had this red
phone and every terrible record was a
movie and they pick it up you know and
then. The name was on the
ship. Easily can be so the other man with that was with
like they was on the ship and he was out in the
early and they saw the lake up one afternoon.
And the it is you little bit a karate you know
this is the get uptight we all the girls in the
thing and then the
city and then. The lead
and there was a whole lot of
girls and there was this big. Cave with the water coming down the
water was down below
them unsolicited from a whole lot of
barrels and we put them in there. He called them
out and he threw around ten or ten girls and
about two one out of the time that was it on the mouth.
And then the level they had said a bomb.
So the alley was this game with a little hillocks and
watch and. And he said all the girls they saw
the
ship. So we were not
Alan and he looked down at the water and he saw the ship always down there.
The hour was gone.
Sonny said. And took us one that right into the
water. May as well Wally to the
ship in the Navy.
Are
here to do
all of us are the most
timely ability of playing that
single lawyer when it comes down.
To that clean come to school then I come
from school and I goes a sailing
class. And then at the sailing class.
I guess lunch and then we come back to school after
school. They use he tells about the cabin clean up and
everything and then at that I go to the best walk
or play softball or
something and then I deal in the nurse's office
in the back playing Battleship.
There's
a
new
school year. All those projects.
Really he sat.
Or about here. There is where he
is really good.
There's a reason. Is.
Is
really the ME. Or clan.
I was using as was the need to save. His legacy.
Here. Earlier
this
year.
We don't go by that because a lot of this was
spite. Is that you got this in the in
the list get
down in the got a clause in the saying we want for the
president and then you vote like. Say I want helpful advice for
that like I nominate Paul was the second in a motion or something
like
that so they use a
younger class on me. He's a president
the
president and with the have
close. On the most savage
tree we get all kinds
of cheers from all the trial. There was it was a
truck. Michael Hirsh truck a big truck getting
near get boxes box car
and take it over there get the seats from the old truck lame
out
there put pictures of things on the
walls. The goalie every
day while bike
live. In the lesson
learned
for.
The U.V..
They used to tell who it is like to use a sun above a
little. So you can see in those
this sound about
Lee. He don't want to waste time and it's more than a saying he said
this out of the
me out of the vaccine for.
You for doing.
Some of the
Dixie you. Think.
As a young mother is a
horrible.